[Music]
a couple of steelers offensive linemen
have the perfect solution for ending all
of the sniping by former members of the
team directed to current members of the
team they've decided to go to social
media and ask nicely that you please
stop as if that ever works essentially
what ramon foster and marquise pounce he
want former members of the team to do is
to
get in touch with them foster and or
pouncy if there's anyone currently in
the building they have a problem with
that they would like to
speak with instead of speaking out
publicly against these people let us
know and we will connect you with them
so you can hash it out man to man face
to face voice to voice and not create
more drama by taking shots on social
media now this overlooks the fact that
guys like antonio brown
probably like taking the shots publicly
and prefer not to do it privately but
you know i i guess it's a message that
at this point they're desperate to send
because they're doing everything they
can to stop this never-ending bleeding
that makes the steelers organization
look worse and worse and worse
well i want to actually ask you that
question mike because at what point you
obviously know the steelers inside and
out what point are the rooneys like this
is actually embarrassing because this is
the culture of the pittsburgh steelers
calling other players out calling other
teammates out
the guys who are
going right now and saying hey everyone
come talk to us man to man don't take it
to social media they're the guys who
also said stuff about le'veon bell
before the season so everyone is to
blame here and at some point are the
rudy's gonna just stand up like hey
we're very embarrassed by how this is
all gone like we have to change
well i i think first you have to
acknowledge that it's a problem and
what's the gift with the guys the the
cartoon characters sitting in the
burning room saying this is fine i mean
i feel like art rooney the owner of the
team is still in denial that there's
even an issue and i think this all flows
back to mike tomlin if chris sims were
here he would be defending mike tomlin
but i think the culture of that
organization the culture in that locker
room is set by the degree of
accountability that is
generated by the head coach and i always
compare and look the steelers have six
super bowl championships the patriots
have six and when when things aren't
going wrong in pittsburgh i look at the
patriots and say what would bill
belichick do about this situation bill
belichick would never let it get to a
point where anyone is saying anything
publicly where any of this stuff is
playing out publicly he would never
allow anyone to think that there's a
different set of rules that apply to
them if antonio brown's showing up late
that's going to be dealt with before he
becomes a diva these things are all
going to be nipped in the bud long
before they become problems and i think
what we're seeing here is the end result
of years of the steelers not having the
kind of culture internally where there
is accountability where there is one set
of rules where there isn't the
opportunity for guys like antonio brown
and ben roethlisberger to do whatever
they want roethlisberger call guys out
publicly if he wants to i mean think of
the irony here you've got current
members of the team saying hey former
members of the team if you're going to
call out any of our guys please let us
know and we can handle it privately you
got a quarterback who's currently on the
team who thinks he has license to call
out anybody anytime he wants and and
does this apply to him too no it only
applies to former players that's their
loophole to avoid them getting in
trouble with ben roethlisberger no
you're absolutely right it's a mike
tomlin issue it's a ben rosensberger
issue i i just don't the whole thing has
been just comical and it's got this
carnival-esque feel to it and it's never
going to stop because antonio brown's
not going to stop talking and if big ben
calls out you you nailed it big ben i go
back to uh this last offseason when they
draft mason rudolph and you have the
whole comments where where ben says you
know what it's not my job to teach him
i'm not going to be his mentor that's
leadership from within that's just not
there
and ben is a hall of fame quarterback
two-time super bowl champion but
sometimes your your best leader is not
your quarterback but you know they get
thrust into that situation and everyone
looks to them and i think that's where
the problem comes from is that your
coach and your quarterback are not
strong leaders in the fact that they can
tell everyone hey look we got to button
it up we have to keep everything in the
in the locker room here we can't be
going to the media we can't be going to
social media you need to have one or the
two and when when the quarterback and
the coach kind of put a blind eye to it
this is how this is how everyone starts
talking this is how you have this
carnival go on for what feels like a
couple years now
and i feel like the the standard that
applies to ben roethlisberger is the
simple result of the fact the steelers
went 20 years between terry bradshaw and
ben roethlisberger without a franchise
quarterback they didn't win a super bowl
during that stretch and they realize
we've got a guy who's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl maybe he doesn't
get the credit for being a great
quarterback that he should but he is a
great quarterback they put up with all
the other stuff because who's going to
be the quarterback and you see they've
been kind of clumsily flailing at trying
to find someone they can groom josh
dobbs one year mason rudolph the next
year who knows what they'll do in the
draft this year they have to be thinking
about life without ben roethlisberger
but until they get to the point where he
is done they got to find a way to make
it work and i feel like they're just
trying to hold it all together as best
they can while they limp to the finish
line of roethlisberger's career and try
to win one more super bowl and that's
just not the way to do it also one of
the other issues with the steelers and i
mentioned this from time to time i feel
like that they've allowed this hey we've
only had three coaches in 50 years to
become such a part of their identity
that they don't hold their current coach
accountable the way they should because
they still want to be able to say we've
only had three coaches in 51 years now
it's 52. now it's 53. look at us we're
going for three coaches in 60 years and
the coach feels like he's never going to
be run out the door because the the
organization takes so much pride in
never firing a coach that the coach can
say hey i don't have to worry about
getting fired
yeah no you're right and i i always
criticize teams that fire coaches too
quickly so i'm not gonna sit here and
say that you know the steelers going the
opposite direction is a bad thing i
think there's a fine balance where coach
can't feel like they're always coaching
for their job and saying hey this next
decision might be the enemy they have to
have the freedom to take risks and take
the correct risks but but at some point
you're right it gets to a point where
it's like mike tomlin can do anything
mike tomlin can have year after year
after year where they don't meet the
expectations and fall short and still
have a job so
you know teams teams do sometimes have
coaches too long i think about even
lovey smith with the bears you know
lovey smith was a good coach lovey smith
was consistent and the bears were good
year after year and uh at least you know
not great but they were in the hunt
and eventually got to a point where it's
like look it's just the same thing year
after year they haven't gotten to that
next level maybe we got to move on and
mike tomlin feels like we they have not
gone to that next level and they missed
the playoffs last year and they lose and
get absolutely embarrassed
to the jaguars the year before
what's gonna happen this year if they
don't get to the playoffs this year and
mike tomlin keeps his job then he does
really feel like he has a job for life
and he does really feel like there are
no repercussions to a locker room that's
kind of falling apart at the seams
and big head i agree with you i don't
like it when teams fire coaches too
quickly but there needs to be a baseline
level of expectation that if you go
below that just like a player we're
going to do what's in the best interest
of the team and we're going to give you
time on the front end we're going to
give you a couple of years three years
maybe four years at the most to try to
get your footing but once you are the
year-to-year head coach we don't just
say okay you've got a job for life
you've got tenure now there still is a
minimum level that you've got to
maintain and if you don't for more than
a couple of years that's when we're
going to make a change now with all that
said one thing i know about the steelers
when the bar is high they don't make it
when the bar is low they soar over it
and with all this stuff there's a way
this year that tomlin can pull all of it
together the acrimony the
everybody is on the browns and how great
they are there's so many different
motivating points out there that if
tomlin does it right he can put together
a very special team there's still a lot
of talent and this is a team that could
over achieve could get to the playoffs
could win some games when they get there
because of the veteran leadership they
have with roethlisberger and tomlin's
been there and done that as well as long
as they don't face the patriots along
the way they could end up maybe making
it to the super bowl this year and it
all flows from taking all of this
negativity and harnessing it the right
way and that's on tomlin and then tom if
tomlin pulls that off then maybe he
should have a job for life but if he
fails this year this may be the time to
start thinking about the fourth coach in
51 years
listen i think that we are in that spot
for the steelers where it's addition by
subtraction with antonio brown and how
it all went down in all the reports and
i am not sympathetic towards ben we've
talked about him at the beginning of
this segment where
you know roethlisberger deserves a lot
of the criticism but in terms of a
day-to-day stress antonio brown going to
the raiders will probably help the
steelers in 2019
phenomenal wide receiver top wide
receiver in the game you can make the
argument you know top three at least but
at some point the distractions get too
much
and i i do think they'll have a little
bit of addition by subtraction because
there's still a ton of talent on the
roster and now you don't have the
headache of antonio brown week to week
what type of mood is he going to be in
on tuesday practice why what type of
mood is he going to be in on the walk
through on saturday will he show up on
sunday is he going to play like you know
there's all these questions and now
they're going to have that eliminated
and get back to football
and also they're going to be paying
attention everything antonio brown does
with the raiders and uh enjoying from
afar if that ends up being the kind of
mess that it could be all right we're
gonna take a break when we return nick
bosa deleted some tweets that were
political in nature should he or any
other athlete be expected to go back and
delete tweets and keep their political
views to themselves as they approach the
draft we'll discuss that when pft live
continues right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports